si la parole est à madame bérengère
poletti merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
les départements sont les grands blessés
de votre réforme territoriale certains
sont moribonds fragilisé par la baisse
des dotations de l'état et la non
compensation des politiques sociales qui
flambent
vous venez de transfuser quelques
départements pour les sauver de la mort
mais sans les guérir et il en reste
beaucoup dans la salles d'attentes
visiblement leur situation ne vous
inspire pas de prise de conscience et
vous tirer sur l'ambulance
à chaque texte vous en rajoutez à la
charge des départements
de plus vous venait d'adresser le 22
décembre dernier
deux instructions aux préfets faisons
une étonnante interprétation de la loi
nôtre il y est martelé que le
département ne peut plus intervenir sur
les aides économiques à partir du 1er
janvier 2016
vous omettez cependant toutes
dispositions transitoires pour assurer
le glissement de la compétence vers les
régions les aides aux entreprises voter
entre le 8 août et la fin de l'année
tombe au 31 décembre 2015
à la fin de cette période notamment en
décembre
le délai administratif est devenue
intenable car il était impossible de
réunir si rapidement les pièces
justificatives
derrière ces aides votées et validé par
les préfets ce sont des entreprises des
artisans des commerçants des emplois de
proximité
cela revient à dire qu'au mois de
décembre 2015
personne ne pouvait aider les
entrepreneurs locaux il y a pourtant des
enjeux sur la baisse du chômage et sur
le rsa dans les ardennes
nous ne sommes pas les seuls
malheureusement 1,5 million d'euros
bloqués pour des projets locaux empêcher
ces aides aux petites entreprises c'est
fabriquer des nouveaux chômeurs
comment allez-vous débloquer cette
situation ubuesque
monsieur le premier ministre le
président de la république veut faire
croire qu'il veut baisser la courbe du
chômage
sur ce dossier
j'ai envie de lui dire chiche merci la
parole et à madame marylise lebranchu
ministre la décentralisation et de la
fonction publique
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la députée que je ne veux plus je veux
absolument reprendre votre dernière
phrase votre avant dernière phrase
les représentants du patronat des
petites entreprises et moyennes
entreprises lui paie à la capeb nous ont
demandé une chose arrêter un système qui
fait qu'en france il y avait treize
mille aides possibles aux entreprises
créé un guichet unique rationaliser des
haines et essayer de mettre tout ça en
musique et je vous rappelle parce que
c'est important que si vous n'avez pas
voté la loi à l'assemblée nationale vos
collègues du parti républicain l'ont
votée au sénat en l'état insistant sur
le fait insistant sur le fait insistant
sur le fait je peux aussi vous faire ça
que il fallait mettre fin au double ils
ont voté ça la circulaire mais la
circulaire ne vous énervez je ne
m'énerve pas la circulaire rappelle à la
demande de l'ensemble en particulier des
élus et des directeurs de service des
compétences de chacun et je vous
rappelle enfin que nous avons d'ailleurs
répondu à une question semblable au
sénat monsieur jacob disant que pour les
aides qui avait été initiée avant le 31
décembre
il est demandé d'avoir une s'était ap
pour savoir sur la région concernée
décide de continuer la délégation de
compétence ou de l'arrêter
et dans le cas de figure je vous donne
rendez-vous et surtout un monsieur
bussereau qui partage votre avis
semble-t-il pour que nous mettions au
point les règles de droit qui couvrent
totalement les départements mais on ne
peut pas continuer à dire comme
j'entends dire depuis si longtemps
qu'ils à un mille feuilles qui a des
doublons et aussitôt qu'on est
est de rationaliser et de mutualiser
parce que ce sont les mêmes
contribuables
on est allé si madame la ministre la
parole est à m